♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WE MAKE THE POINT A
LOT ON THIS SHOW BECAUSE IT'S
TRUE THAT THE ENTIRE PURPOSE OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY'S
IMMIGRATION POLICY IS TO CHANGE
THE POPULATION OF THE
UNITED STATES IN A WAY THAT
GUARANTEES THEY WOULD MAKE EVERY
ELECTION GOING FORTH.
THIS IS ESSENTIALLY ELECTORATE
HACKING AND IT'S AN ASSAULT ON
DEMOCRACY.
EVERY TIME WE SAY IT ONLINE THE
USUAL LAYERS AND DUMMIES WHO
IMAGINE THEMSELVES TO BE THE
GATEKEEPERS OF OUR NATIONAL
CONVERSATION THAT WILL FIT, THEY
BECOME APOPLECTIC AND CALL US
THE USUAL NAMES, BOO-HOO.
THEN AFTER A FEW DAYS, THE MOST
INTERESTING PART, THEY
INEVITABLY GO BACK TO BRAGGING A
PUBLIC ABOUT HOW THEY ARE USING
IMMIGRATION POLICY TO CHANGE THE
POPULATION OF THE UNITED STATES
TO CHANGE THE ELECTIONS GOING
FORWARD AND EXPECT US NOT TO
NOTICE.
A COLUMNIST AT
"THE WASHINGTON POST," RUBEN IS
PROBABLY THE DUMBEST PERSON EVER
TO HAVE A NEWSPAPER COLUMN, SHE
DOES THIS A LOT, SHE HAS NO SELF
AWARENESS AND DID THIS THE OTHER
DAY AND PRINT HOPING NO ONE
WOULD NOTICE BUT WE DID.
DEMOCRATIC HOPES THAT DEMOGRAPHY
WOULD DELIVER TEXAS HAVE NOT
BEEN WRONG BUT PERHAPS
PREMATURE.
THE 2020 CONGRESSIONAL RACES
SUGGEST THAT WHILE THE FIGHT FOR
HISPANIC VOTES REMAIN
COMPETITIVE THE SPRAWLING
SUBURBS AROUND MAJOR CITIES ARE
INCREASINGLY MODERATE.
OH, IN OTHER WORDS, THE GREAT
REPLACEMENT PLAN IS WORKING.
IT'S HELPING THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THAT IS THE
WHOLE POINT.
THANKS FOR TELLING US THAT, AND
LET US KNOW, IF IT'S RACIST,
READ YOUR COLUMN OUT LOUD.
SO HUNTER BIDEN, IN CONTRAST TO
A LOT OF OTHER PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY IS IN A REALLY GOOD
PLACE RIGHT NOW.
HE HAS BECOME A PAINTER,
FINGERPAINTING, APPARENTLY, AND
HE'S BEEN SELLING HIS WORKS FOR
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
TO UNNAMED FOREIGN BUYERS
BECAUSE THAT IS TOTALLY
LEGITIMATE.
PEOPLE CRITICIZED HIM FOR THIS,
WHAT DOES HE THINK?
HE DOESN'T CARE WHAT YOU THINK.
>> IF I WAS GOING TO CHOOSE
SOMETHING, TO BECOME AN ARTIST
AND SUBJECT YOURSELF TO THAT,
THE NORMAL CRITICISM OF SHARING
YOUR ART TO A WIDER AUDIENCE IS,
YOU KNOW, AT LEAST IN MY BOOK IT
IS A PRETTY COURAGEOUS THING TO
DO.
>> YOU SEEM TO HAVE GOOD SPIRITS
ABOUT THIS CRAZED NARRATIVE
AROUND YOUR PAINTING.
WHAT IS YOUR RESPONSE TO THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE COMING AFTER THE
PRICES OF THE WORK OR THE
COLLECTORS, WHAT HAS BEEN YOUR
RESPONSE TO THAT?
>> OTHER THAN [BLEEP] THEM?
>> [LAUGHS]
>> Tucker: HONESTLY, IT IS
KIND OF HARD TO BLAME HUNTER
BIDEN FOR THIS.
IF SOMEONE IS GOING TO PAY YOU
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
FOR YOUR ART, YOU JUST TOOK UP
THE HOBBY A COUPLE MINUTES AGO,
WOULD YOU TAKE THE MONEY?
OF COURSE HE WOULD.
99% OF PEOPLE WOULD.
IT'S EVERYONE ELSE WHO IS
IMPLICATED IN THIS.
THE PEOPLE INTERVIEWING HUNTER
BIDEN AND CALLING ANY CRITICISM
OF HIS ART CAREER
HYPERVENTILATING, IT'S ALL
POLITICAL, OF THE PEOPLE BUYING
CRAP ENTIRELY BECAUSE IT
IS THE PRESIDENT'S SON AND
PRETENDING IT IS NOT HAPPENING,
THOSE OF THE VILLAINS.
HUNTER BIDEN IS JUST A MAN ON
THE MAKE GETTING WHAT HE CAN AND
HE'S GETTING A LOT.
HUNDREDS OF RICH PEOPLE AROUND
CALIFORNIA, INCLUDING THE MAYOR
OF THE RAPIDLY DISINTEGRATING
CITY OF LOS ANGELES, ERIC
GARCETTI.
HE WAS THERE.
WHY MIGHT THAT BE?
BECAUSE HE IS A HUGE ART FAN?
BECAUSE HUNTER BIDEN AFTER 50
YEARS OF DOING WHATEVER HE'S
BEEN DOING, SPENT THAT BECOMING
A GREAT ARTIST?
NOW, HE'S JUST NOMINATED HIM TO
BE THE AMERICAN AMBASSADOR OF
INDIA.
HE APPEARS IN HUNTER BIDEN'S
LAPTOP ON A LIST OF KEY CONTACT
TO GREASE THE WHEELS OF THE
CHINESE BUSINESS PARTNERS.
IT'S A REPULSIVE, ACTUALLY
HAPPENING NOW.
SO SERVE THE WORLD.
MIRANDA DEVINE HAS CHRONICLED IT
LIKE NO ONE ELSE AND WE ARE
GRATEFUL TO HAVE HER TONIGHT.
IF YOU PURCHASED ONE OF THESE
PAINTINGS?
>> I HAVE NOT, THEY ARE REALLY
OUT OF MY PRICE RANGE.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT UP TO
$500,000 AND THEY DON'T REALLY
STRIKE ME AS BEING SO GOOD THAT
I WANT THEM ON MY WALLS.
MAYBE AS A NOVELTY ITEM, I THINK
A LOT OF PEOPLE WOULD BE BUYING
AT BECAUSE HUNTER BIDEN IS NOW
BECOMING SO NOTORIOUS THROUGH
HIS LAPTOP, 1 OF 3 THAT HE HAS
MISLAID AROUND THE PLACE, AND
YOU KNOW, WE CAN LAUGH AT HIM
AND AS YOU SAY, HE DOESN'T CARE,
HE'S UNTOUCHABLE NOW.
HIS FATHER IS THE PRESIDENT AND
WHATEVER GRAFT HE'S UP TO, IT'S
REALLY JOE BIDEN'S GRIFF, THE
PRESIDENT'S GRAPH, THE
WHITE HOUSE'S GRIFF, SO IS
EVERYONE'S PROBLEM, PARTICULARLY
THE DEMOCRATS AND ANYONE WHO
GOES TO THESE HUNTER BIDEN ART
SHOWS, THERE IS ANOTHER ONE
HAPPENING IN NEW YORK LATER ON
IN THE FALL, IF THEY GO, THEY
ARE LEGITIMIZING WHAT IS REALLY
JUST A RACKET.
>> Tucker: THE ENTIRE ART
WORLD IS A TAX DODGE AND THAT IS
WELL KNOWN, I'M NOT SURE A LOT
OF PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THAT BUT A
LOT OF IT IS ABOUT TAX
AVOIDANCE, OF COURSE.
BUT WHAT ABOUT ALL THE SO-CALLED
ART CRITICS AND NEWSPAPER
REPORTERS WHO UNDER ANY OTHER
CIRCUMSTANCES WOULD BE COVERING
THIS WITH AT LEAST AMUSEMENT OR
TOTALLY IGNORING IT.
>> LIKE EVERYTHING THAT PLAYS
BADLY FOR JOE BIDEN, BEFORE THE
ELECTION WHEN WE PUBLISHED THE
STORY IS ON THE LAPTOP THAT WERE
SUPPRESSED AND YOU HAVE SEEN IT
EVER SINCE.
ANYTHING THAT IS NEGATIVE ABOUT
JOE BIDEN IS COVERED UP AND
EXCUSED AND EXPLAINED AWAY AND
ANY BAD OPTICS ARE QUICKLY
MOPPED UP.
I GUESS THAT IS WHAT THE
WHITE HOUSE IS GOOD AT.
WE KNOW THAT HUNTER BIDEN IS
UNDER INVESTIGATION FOR MONEY
LAUNDERING, AMONG OTHER
PROBLEMS, AND WE KNOW THAT THE
ART WORLD IS NOTORIOUS FOR BEING
A VENUE FOR MONEY LAUNDERING, SO
IT REALLY TAKES A LOT OF
CHUTZPAH, THE WORD OF THE BITE
ADMINISTRATION IS SHAMELESSNESS.
IT'S SHAMELESS THAT THE
PRESIDENT ISN'T EVEN PRETENDING
TO DISTANCE HIMSELF FROM WHAT IS
GOING ON AND CONTINUING TO HIDE
BEHIND THE MIRAGE OF BEING A
KINDLY, FATHERLY FAMILY MAN WHEN
HE'S BEEN IN ON THIS INFLUENCE
PEDDLING ENRICHMENT PROGRAM FROM
THE START.
>> Tucker: NONE OF THESE
PEOPLE EVER DO ANYTHING USEFUL.
WHY NOT USE HVAC REPAIR, HOW TO
FIX A DIESEL INJURY OR DRYWALL.
IT'S ALWAYS SOME B.S., FAKE
GRIFF.
I'M A LOBBYIST, I'M AN ARTIST.
HE CAN'T DO ANYTHING, THESE ARE
USELESS PEOPLE.
>> IT'S NOT REALLY HUNTER'S
FAULT, HE WAS ALWAYS BROUGHT UP
TO BE THE BAD MAN.
>> Tucker: YOU'RE TOTALLY
RIGHT, I AGREE.
I'VE NEVER BLAMED HIM,